welcome back to the 52nd ever episode of
the iced coffee hour
my name is proto doge and i have made
2.3 million dollars
with dogecoin that was incredible we got
to keep that
that was a great inch look at that that
was so
well this is unexpected this is a
totally last-minute episode the first
time
ever that we're posting on a saturday
instead of a sunday we had to get this
out as soon as possible
you hit me up andre like 20 minutes in
advance and said hey
are you home i want to stop by i have a
guest i want you to meet yep
it was none other than the dogecoin
millionaire so
i found pro on reddit i found your story
it blew up it got to like
70 000 up votes yeah crazy i was like
dude i did not think you would respond
to me because i imagine your inbox was
just blown up
oh i learned my lesson i missed the
forbes interview
because i didn't know how to check my
messages yeah so you got hit up by
everybody business insider forbes
newsweek cnbc
nbc so i reached out to you and i was
like there's no way this guy's gonna
respond to me
and i reached out i was like i love your
story i'd love to connect i'd love to do
a video with you
you responded in like five minutes i'm
all my i mean
i'm on my game how about this you could
swear we're just going to bleep
it out that's fine we want you to be you
okay yeah cause i cuss
yeah yeah so five minutes later you
respond and
i'm like bro you got to come out now i
gotta go see you
and then i went to you to la to film
that video which blew up
yeah now it's got over like 600 000
views it's crazy it's insane and then
and then i had a youtube channel
and on april 22nd i screenshotted my
channel before i met andre
and it was at 200 subscribers right now
currently i'm sitting at eight point
five thousand graduates you're about to
be ten thousand
subscribe everyone go subscribe down
below in the description
do people love you they love your story
and i think what people love about you
the most is
is not that you yellowed into dogecoin
it's how you live it's so
it's so frugal explain it because i have
a feeling some of our audience doesn't
understand the greatness who's sitting
down in this couch right now
explain your story and what led up to
that reddit post which blew up and now
you're making like two million dollars
you're you're up a million dollars in
the last like
24 hours 20 a million dollars so explain
the story
so okay uh i'm trying to figure out how
far back i should go here
uh as far back as you want yeah go back
a year ago let's say yeah yeah okay
one year ago um so i talked to andre
about this but i make sixty thousand
dollars a year
at my current job and i still work there
paycheck to paycheck paying my bills
what do you do
um i work at a hip hop music media
company
so i actually do voiceovers i do video
editing
i do uh thumbnails graphics photoshop
i pretty much do everything over there
and i've been there for a few years now
and so you know just living life regular
but i've also saved money
really well over the you know past few
years a lot of people don't know that
you know everybody sees what's happening
now
but they don't know what how i saved up
180 grand to begin with which i feel
like
that's the part we should focus on
because everybody can save money if they
do it the right way you know what i mean
so had it in stocks had it in tesla
had it in uber had it in carnival cruise
lines shout out to jeremy
i had it in uh i got a few other ones
you know what i mean and then gamestop
happened
earlier this year and so i had never
been on reddit a day in my life i
literally
got ready started researching gamestop
realized this was an opportunity that
things were changing
and we needed to jump on there with the
little guy and help out and go against
these hedge funds
and i actually put some money in the
game stop i lost some money in the
gamestop
and once the craziness happened with
robin hood
when they you know disabled the buy
button and you couldn't buy anymore i
realized
the system was just rigged like this is
illegal they can't do this it's
ridiculous
so that's when i started looking at
other ways of investing so while i'm on
reddit
i see a post where someone's like has
dogecoin ever been to a dollar
and i'm like what the hell is dogecoin
and that's when i started researching
about dogecoin
found out about it and um yeah i did a
bunch of just like my personal research
combined with um some technical analysis
of the graphs that i looked over the
years and years and years and kind of
saw how you know the moves were
and i also created and developed this
bullish thesis
on it becoming the future of currency
and how that can happen one day and like
the possibilities of that
and yolo'd my 180 thousand dollars
into doge and in 69 days
no kidding 69 days i became a
millionaire
what was the the main driving factor for
your bullish thesis
how much okay my main driving factor for
the bullish thesis
was i feel like three things i feel like
it was the branding
of dogecoin i feel like out of all the
cryptocurrencies doge has
the best branding there is like as far
as
memes and can i interrupt you real quick
go ahead so
this morning we were filming for my
friday video
and we went to unlv our local university
here in vegas
and he's all about branding thank you
sorry that's one of the major reasons
we were asking college kids have they
ever heard about dogecoin right so we
asked one and they were like a dogecoin
or like doggy coin oh yeah yeah that one
so we got one
to notice here but we asked like i would
say oh we had
we had one dude that was actually mad
because it's dipping right now and he's
losing a little bit of money dude
we asked like 30 people and i would say
maybe three of them knew what it was and
we
said dogecoin doggy coin dog coin
they're like no i don't know what that
is you like do you know crypto they're
like
not really yeah they didn't even know
crypto though like you know
it's a college student it's a college
kid they don't have money to be fair
that's the demographic though i feel
like that would know chris to be fair
when you were 18 and you were in college
did you really
care about money as i mean yeah we were
exceptional
like most people didn't really probably
didn't care about that stuff
they would i don't know when i was in
college
no one cared about investing aside from
me no one did there you go that's what
i'm saying because
they don't have any money and they're
young it's like it takes time to start
thinking about like this is my thing you
can't think of investing until you have
the money to start
putting it places right right so if i'm
living paycheck to paycheck
i can't even think of it like if i think
of tesla as an investment i don't even
have the money to put it in yes you do
you could have the money to get a free
stock worth all the way up to 50
down below in the description when you
sign up for public
but back to the points uh so my point is
branding
my second point is community which i
feel like a lot of people
underestimate i feel like community
behind dogecoin is probably one of the
strongest if not the strongest
in crypto um there's a backbone there
right dogecoin almost had a cult
following up until this year
where people were along for the ride the
entire way
hodling diamond handing for years and
this kind of like
just happened and all of a sudden the
world knows about it and it's one of
those things where it's like the
community
aspect of it and just the camaraderie
around dogecoin is incredible
were you nervous though you sold
everything right my understanding was
you sold everything
you took on some debt to buy this
explain this what did you sell what did
you take
okay um i sold all my stocks and i also
borrowed on margin which i don't suggest
anybody does
it's super risky and it was you got
called out
i did i did so what happened with the
margin a lot of people are worried about
this because like man you
like your margin what are you doing
about that so i paid it all back all of
the margin that i bought
paid back i initially had purchased five
million dogecoins which means i would be
up a lot higher right now
than the 2.3 million but that was worth
about
uh 250 250 k in dogecoin
and the margin was 50 000 right
i didn't really like
i figured okay whenever robinhood wants
the money back whenever i have to pay
that back dogecoin is going to be up
anyway
then i'll pay less than what i borrowed
right that was my thought process
sure enough it got to a point where
robinhood was like hey we want our money
back
so they force sold a million of my
friends
was that because dogecoin dropped i was
getting margin called
yep so what was happening was i bought
it at 0.045 so whenever it touched it
and went down
it would be like margin called marginal
if i'm not paying it back robinhood is
going to sell all your stocks
guess what i had no stocks so i wasn't
worried i was like you can't sell my
stocks
didn't know they'd sell my coins but
they did so they sold a million of my
coins
which equaled not only the 50k but i had
fees and all this other stuff
uh packed in which means the total
amount they sold was seventy seven
thousand so it was twenty seconds
so you borrowed 50 but you paid back 77
000 how do they charge you 27 000
and that's like that's pained like more
than 50 on your it's ridiculous
there's there's probably technicalities
there that i don't know exactly where
they pulled it from but that's the
amount they came to
so they sold 77k which means my my 5
million dogecoin
right now is about 4 million but the
thing is this when i bought the 5
million i bought it at 0.045
right when robin hood sold it all they
sold it at .055
so that that that difference in a penny
means
that same difference from the 50k to 77k
so it ended up being about the same
thing because my profit was about 20k
do you see what i'm saying so it ended
up working out for me so the amount that
i have in those right now is
all my money it's 188k pro what is the
exact amount that you have in dogecoin
right now because we checked about 50
minutes ago and what was what was the
amount 2 million
230 000 that was 50 minutes ago let's
see what it is
right now right in a second but first we
have to thank this video sponsor
grammarly there have been so many times
in my life where i've had trouble
writing effectively or expressing myself
clearly for example usually when we
invite people onto this podcast it
requires me to invite the guest via dm
and i want to make sure that i don't
come off weird and my writing is concise
and accurate yeah i remember when i was
a real estate agent it was really
important for me to write my emails good
really
in cases like that it really helps to
have grammarly premium
grammarly is a digital writing assistant
that will review any writing that you do
and tell you how your tone comes off
give you alternative vocab suggestions
and help with your structure i know not
everyone has to dm people trying to get
them onto their podcast but grammarly
premium can be used in plenty of
situations such as checking in on your
family
sending recaps to teams in your
organization or sharing big news with
your friends i find myself using
grammarly premium more and more as time
goes on just because of how easy it is
plus it's nice to know that when i do
send a message to someone none of my
intentions can be lost in how they
receive the message
on top of all this grammarly makes me a
better writer which i think is a very
important skill to have
evaluate your writing with 20 off
grammarly premium at grammarly.com
iced coffee that's 20 off grammarly
premium at grammarly g-r-a-m-m-a-r-l-y
dot com slash iced coffee thank you so
much grammarly for sponsoring this
episode and back to the podcast
it's at 2.7575
wow so you just made 45 000
that's a tesla you made a tesla in 50
minutes
exactly does that not bot like does that
not
at least sleep at night yeah i like do
you see baby do you smell like a baby
like my diamond hands are so
strong that i sleep like an infant
do you not worry that this could you
could lose a million dollars and like
overnight
i don't think it would ever drop to that
level
but let's say it does let's say it drops
a lot right
i'm buying the dip so what do you think
what money oh how would you buy the
paycheck coming next week from work two
thousand you're saying you put two
like two three thousand dollars in doge
with the paycheck yeah
you would put your entire paycheck no no
i wouldn't put the entire paycheck i
would i would buy little by little but
this is the thing though
since realizing that robin hood didn't
allow me to move my currency my
cryptocurrency in and out
once i realized that i was like okay
that's it i'm not buying a robin anymore
so
i went and got crack in started using
that so
since the robin hood purchase of 188k i
purchased another three thousand dollars
worth of dogecoin
off a kraken and moved it to my coinbase
wallet that three
thousand dollars right now do you wanna
see how much it's worth yeah i do
i just wait so the two point three
million dollars that's not all of it
no sir uh my coinbase wallet that three
thousand is not worth it
[Music]
so 37 000 that's 3 000 dollar investment
that's crazy but don't you think that
the dollar cost average just buying the
dip is insignificant in relation to what
you have in it it's like what is that
okay buy the dip no that's true i'll
tell you it's more of a personal reason
so with me
i don't know if i'm ocd or what it is
but i need exactly four million
dogecoins
and at the moment in time i have three
million nine hundred
and five thousand dogecoins in my robin
hood and i purchased sixty thousand
dogecoin on kraken
so i'm i'm shy thirty five thousand
thirty five dollars so you need to spend
another seventeen thousand dollars
roughly to get to that
yeah and i just wanna have four million
so what do you think is going to happen
today
uh i think i think that has what's to oh
today
well today when this goes what do i
think is going to happen today on
saturday
yeah today just to be clear we're
recording this on it's thursday
at 308 p.m yeah okay what do i think is
going to happen yeah
saturday the the rumor right now is that
elon musk
is he's going to be on snl and the
the thinking is that he's talked so much
about dogecoin that he's going to
work it into a skit maybe he's gonna pay
for something in dogecoin or
put a yes dogecoin on the moon or
something like that and just the mere
mention of that is going to cause the
price to hit a dollar
and it seems like that dollar is the
threshold where everyone wants to hit a
dollar and then
so the disagreement is some people think
it's going to pump if he mentions it and
some people think
i happen to be one of them and i'm sure
graham is too and jack well i don't know
about jack but
uh that it's gonna sell off and i think
i think it's gonna sell off but why do
you think it's not
why do you think it's gonna pump the
reason why i think it's gonna pump
let's be realistic here i don't think
it's gonna go to a dollar personally i
really don't it's
it's too you realize you just crash the
price
i think it's gonna go to five dollars
actually like the deep effing value of
dogecoin
yeah where like what you say will impact
i think possibly
in fact at least i think a few hundred
people would take whatever you say
is gospel and if you're selling you're
selling if you hold
they're holding you want to know
something funny and and um how you
mentioned
uh deep [ __ ] value yeah so people on
reddit
call me doge [ __ ] value people on
reddit also call me
the doge father they also call me
slumdoge millionaire
and this is the story of the underdoge
that's the reservoir doge so i get
everything so you don't think it's gonna
hit
what do you think the peak is going to
be all right if i had to take a guess
right now elon musk is going to do a
skit something about dogecoin
saturday night live i feel like the
price is going to rise
from what it is right now which is about
60 to 65 cents
i feel like it'll go to maybe 75.80
that's if i had to take a guess that's
what i think
and then what's going to happen
afterwards it'll probably drop to 60 the
next day
but that's the day that's what the same
day sunday
or yeah i think it's going to drop half
the same day possibly but the thing is
this i've seen this before i've seen
doge go from a penny
to eight cents to back to two cents then
i saw doge go from
five cents to 48 cents back to 25 cents
to 20 cents
now doge is that up to now doge is up to
60 65 cents
if it goes up to 80 cents i see it
dropping back down to 50 cents
like i see this happening but it's
always going up
but since i've left pro here's the thing
crypto has like these super cycles right
like we get
and so if we dip again it doesn't
necessarily mean we'll retrace back to
50 cents like bitcoin could go back down
to 20
000. 10 000 for all we know and if
dogecoin goes back down to say 10 cents
5 cents again do you really think that
the people that are holding now
the retail investors are they really
going to like diamond hand it through
because i don't think they will
but what if i still do and you do
but you don't think people would just
off the strength
like like if i if i'm in if he's in i'm
still in
i'm holding if it goes down to five
cents you're holding yeah i'll hold
but here's the thing if jack were up two
million dollars
i don't think he would be working here
anymore if he didn't sell i would say
like jack the goods because this is like
you would fire me if i didn't sell it if
you had two million dollars
and you're just like i'm holding through
it it's i'm i want a little more
grabs like get the [ __ ] out
get out no you're you're right i would
probably deserve to be right at that
yeah
but you would sell you would sell
because
he's looking at you you would though you
would though
in the next few years a lot could change
you could have a family you could want
to buy a house like
would you really be able to see your
account of 180 000
is just chilling there and you're just
like i'm just going to wait like i don't
know if that's
practical do you think we reached that
peak already do you think from
like it's down that's not the point the
point is that from one bull market to
the next
it seems hypothetically easy to be like
well it was worth 2.7 million and now
it's 200 but i'll hold until it's worth
10. it's like it's not that
simple to put it in perspective i just
did the math on this
okay you sold today today and you kept
your job 65 000 dollars a year sixty
that's equivalent to 31 years
of income to get to two million yes
that's the same what about 100 percent
of it taxes and sales i didn't include
taxes on either one and that's assuming
you say to 100
right saving which is important 31
years more realistic could be 62 years
no no because i'm not counting taxes on
the gain just because i'm not counting
tax on the
oh sure there you go okay so 31 years
you're giving up potentially 31 years of
your life
to potentially get a little more aren't
you worried that maybe that's
now now we're getting into the greed
category where it's like
you were blessed with this moment i mean
no facts and now it's like well i could
get a little more
and and you get a little more okay
you're like i can get a little more
get a little more i could still get a
little more and you keep
trying to get a little more but you risk
every time you keep
a little more you risk the whole thing
going down
31 years no facts facts the thing with
me is like
i went into this from the very beginning
saying i'm gonna hold for a year so like
that was like
i didn't expect to hit what i hit within
69 days
i thought it was gonna take six months
eight months i i figured eventually it'd
go up
right the fact that it happened so early
kind of
signals to me like this might be bigger
than i had even assumed
given the fact that i'm so bullish and
it it exceeded my expectations
of when to reach what i thought it would
reach so now i'm just like wait
is this the peak i don't think so i feel
like we got
some a few more months to go but what's
the difference between two million
and six million is that worth waiting a
month i wouldn't risk it
okay how about you jack i i
realistically i would not risk it either
i i'm sorry but i do think that
2.2 million or whatever that's way too
much money just to leave back
one more round of roulette yeah i would
say anything above a million dollars
that that's enough i mean that that is
really enough give them taxes and
everything because technically
you'd have 600k like you can't really do
much with 600k yeah
i mean especially considering like the
circumstances of your income like i said
if you were making half a million a year
that's a different story
yeah but you're making 60k a year which
i'm not saying is bad
but in relation to what graham said
that's 31 years
yeah that's a lot no that's true that's
true but i also have
you know other aspirations in life i
don't i'm not going to be at a job with
this
what would you do with that extra two
million dollars but first we have to
thank this video sponsor ladder life
insurance
just last night dogecoin was pushing 69
cents which means i was up over
15 000 on my initial investment of a
hundred dollars it's moments like those
that serve as a reminder of how
beautiful life is and exactly why it
should be protected on that note it
makes sense why people get life
insurance especially long-term coverage
which is actually surprisingly
affordable why not pay a little bit each
month to protect the ones that you love
if you're asking yourself this question
choose ladder ladder makes it
impressively easy to get covered you
just need a few minutes and a phone or a
laptop to apply and ladder smart
algorithms work in real time so you'll
find out instantly if you're approved
and there are no hidden fees and you can
cancel at any time and since life
insurance costs more as you age now is
the perfect time to cross it off your
list so check out ladder today to see if
you're instantly approved go to
ladderlife.com
iced coffee that's ladder
l-a-d-d-e-r-life dot com slash iced
coffee ladderlife.com iced coffee
thank you so much ladder for sponsoring
this episode and back to the podcast
um after taxes and everything
let's just say a million an extra
million dollars in your account what
would that do for you
that would be more like okay i really
want to buy my mama house
okay that's one i really want to buy my
mama
a car my aunt is also
really big part of my life and she's got
two little kids you know what i mean and
a family and they live
in a not very good neighborhood so i
want to get her house
so i want to make sure my immediate
family is good before i even get myself
anything
and if i'm taking out a million that
doesn't do it
the thing is it's like when you're on an
airplane and those things drop down
you got to put the mask on yourself
first before you can no that's true
that's very true you got to make sure
you're in a position where you could do
that and you're risking
nobody is in that position now
if something happens you could you got
immigrant mentality bro
maybe maybe you have a you have the
potential to do that
because what you could do is cash out
now let's say you have a million and a
half okay
yeah 500 000 go and buy a house pay for
it cash you never have to worry about it
a million dollars put in the market
every eight years that thing is gonna
double so eight years from now
you could pretty much i would say with
70 certainty
have the full amount of money except
you're playing it safer and you're
waiting eight years
and you can help them out with that
money this is true
i also have like i said other
aspirations
i want to start a record label of my own
i have
artists that i'm ready to sign and
the music is ready and everything's been
ready the reason i even moved to la
was to get an artist sign that i was
managing i was able to get him
signed to a label within a year that
fizzled out a few years later because
you know issues with the label last year
he left the label
so now it's like i need to start this
record label i need to get his music out
there i need to put money behind that so
that's one
i also want my immediate family make
sure they're okay i also
want to start my own rap music media
youtube page the same thing i do at my
work and all these other things i do i
want to start a brand with that
i also want to run with the dogecoin
millionaire brand
merchandise all this other stuff you
know what i mean like everything kind of
i have big dreams and big ideas that i
need money for to fund
you could do all of that with one and a
half million dollars you think so yes
all of it a hundred percent savvy you
can probably do it
not only that but just to say you can't
keep your current job right now and
continue to make 65 000
in addition to the 30 000 a year that
you're gonna make putting a million
dollars in the market
three percent a year you're gonna make
almost a hundred thousand dollars a year
just doing your thing with a paid off
house you could save pretty much
all of it got a big chunk of money in
the bank starting a youtube channel you
know music youtube channel like that
that doesn't cost any money a lot of
this you could do you could bootstrap it
in the beginning
do you consider yourself a full-time
youtuber yes could you have a job right
now
no i wouldn't be able to keep a job if
that went all in
i worked full-time as a real estate
agent first two years
while i was still doing this but you're
doing i agree
with the amount that you do it now
correct no
i i pretty much did i was working from
like 8 a.m to
almost 2 a.m every single day okay for
first two years and i didn't quit well i
i almost said i didn't quit
but i didn't scale back on my career as
a real estate agent
well past the point where i was making a
million dollars a year on youtube i kept
the same level of enthusiasm and
momentum selling like he's selling a
house
yeah as he did with the youtube channel
okay it really it was not until
uh covet hit and you know i was inside
that i was like okay i'm gonna give
youtube
a hundred percent but do you feel like
that okay
given that time period did you see an
incredible level of
increase once you gave it your all yes
that's what i'm saying i i want to be
able to do that but
you do that once once you get to that
point like i wouldn't have just like say
okay i'm gonna
you know quit real estate to just do
youtube like the youtube thing was
already making
double what i was doing as a as an agent
my best year as an agent i was doubling
that
at that point yeah yeah the money you
have now allows you to
have the time to basically do that
youtube thing to pursue that full-time
career without actually having a job
now if you sell now invest that money in
the market
you have enough money for yourself to
not only buy the house but also have
enough free time on your hands
to build up that business that you want
and on top of that if you moved yourself
and your family over to vegas you saved
so much money that's true i think you
got to have the mentality that if you
can't
if you can't be successful with a music
career while also working another job
i think it goes to show you that like
the people who i see really do well make
it work
while keeping a job almost everybody has
done that
yeah i see very few people be like i
need to go in full
force in the very beginning otherwise
it's not going to work even the people
who have created these incredible
e-commerce stores from what i've seen
they're going to school full-time yeah
they're they're you know getting
great grades in college but meanwhile
they're working really hard on this
e-commerce store and then
only to the point where like that
actually started making money doing
really well
did they did they transition that's true
you gotta be able to do it two things at
once
to get it to the point where you could
do that and you have the opportunity to
do that already like i told you in vegas
there's plenty of job opportunities for
exactly what you're doing or
you know we had an extra channel for
example yeah that would be the extra
income for you right there so you have
the opportunity
but even if you didn't take it even if
you did go full in like like what i did
when i started my youtube channel
because i didn't have a job i just quit
cold turkey that's all i did was youtube
yeah
like you still can do that this is this
is true here's the other thing is you
want to continue to the the
dogecoin brand yeah that brand is only
valuable
if dogecoin stays as high as it is if
dogecoin goes down to let's say
five cents which i think honestly it's
probably unlikely that you're ever going
to lose money in this
really i agree it is unlikely if it does
go back down to even let's say
15 cents the dogecoin millionaire aspect
i still have 5x
my money which is impressive but it's
not
the same as you making like two and a
half million dollars
could you make the point that if you
sell now
as a successful millionaire is actually
yeah that was the point i didn't think
about
yeah well like now that you've realized
being a millionaire let's say if you did
sell
it's like you're a success story that's
been cemented in history
but if you lose it then it's like oh
that guy's an idiot yeah it's like
he's forgotten about another one of
those there are so many stories of
people
making it big but somehow losing just
lose it all
yeah there's more stories of that than
people i think who have cashed out
maybe didn't maximize their you know how
much they would have made
but nobody's gonna time the time yeah
yeah yeah you got out well
you made more money than most people
make in a lifetime in a year
yeah i think most people would look at
that even if dogecoin one day goes to
two dollars
okay they would look at you and be like
i wish i could have done that
here's a great example and i don't know
if you guys saw this tweet but this
tweet goes around in circulation every
once in a while right
there was the guy i forgot his name he
made it tweet
and he was like damn it i'm so pissed i
sold my 1 000 bitcoins
for 30 cents when i bought it at six
cents because now it's eight dollars
and it's the funniest i've seen that and
then it's
oh yeah it was great yeah
and then it crashed ninety percent down
to thirty dollars and then then it
crashed ninety percent down to a hundred
dollars
yeah and that's something you're gonna
have to live with i mean
yeah but for every person that says that
about bitcoin there were people who said
i'm so glad i got out of bit connect
when i did yeah what's big big
that was like the biggest scam in crypto
history or one of them but the thing is
this you do you i'm not saying though
the thing okay 2021 do you think that
those
things can still occur like they did
back when it was a brand new thing and
there were sites coming up and down like
everywhere
scams and stuff like that wait if that
could happen again like the same type of
scams that happened back then today
they're
still going on now oh all the time
they're everywhere yeah
okay by the way we we got a new one what
was that one we had to block
so by the way the new scam right now
it's just a heads up it's the comment
section
the comment section yeah all right
everything everything bad happens in the
comments
but we started getting all these
comments like dude you should make a
review on this on this one coin yeah
bonfire yeah
that was it dude check out bonfire i
just made a hundred percent it's nuts
and and at first i'm like oh [ __ ] maybe
maybe i make a video on bonfire like
this is crazy and so i put it in my
notes bonfire
bonfire bond buy and then i look at my
uh my uh
video and those are fake now all of a
sudden they have like a hundred likes
in a matter of like a few minutes i'm
like there's no way this is real
and when you're getting 30 40 comments
check out bonfire oh my god
and it's different every week and then
it's a student coin or long gate or
whatever it is
right right so i started blocking those
things but uh even safe moon was one of
those what about i was about to say that
what about safe moon
first we have to thank soundcore for
sponsoring this episode
[Music]
jack you know we could hear that right
what yeah you should put
these on oh what are these these are the
soundcore liberty air 2 pros which are
actually the best pair of earbuds i have
ever had
let me just say these earbuds are
absolutely amazing they have targeted
active noise cancelling that you can
toggle on and off
super easily within the app and they're
endorsed by 10 grammy award-winning
artists
wait a second how did you know that
graham little birdie told me
and they are the best alternative to big
brands and in fact i actually prefer
these to the big brands mother's day is
right around the corner and there is not
a better gift to give than the liberty
air 2 pros
i love using these things when i'm
working out getting back to you guys in
the comments section
or just relaxing wait a second you're
relaxing
no no that's besides the point gram but
anyways these amazing earbuds actually
have here id
which analyzes your sound profile and
adjusts the levels to make it sound
perfect for your ears plus they have six
noise cancelling microphones so if
you're out in public making a phone call
your audio will come across
perfectly plus they got up to 26 hours
with the play time so either grab
yourself a pair or surprise your mom
with a pair of liberty air 2 pros with
the link in the description trust me you
will absolutely love these guys
thank you so much soundcore for
sponsoring this episode and back to the
podcast yeah well i did a video about
that and that was my conclusion
and i was trying to be so careful about
how i did it because it doesn't matter
when it comes to crypto
crypto is a religion most people don't
research and that's truly understand it
so even if you
that's true if you told them to get out
it's like the most offensive thing right
interesting thing too is uh i did a
video on bitcoin and
there's a big difference by the way that
that just like yeah i don't wanna call
dogecoin a scam
yeah uh so this just goes back to the
mindset of
speaking against something yeah and
actually i do like dogecoin
so i i love those in all the sincerity
like i do actually like dogecoin i think
it's fantastic but
um i made a video about bitconnect
calling bitconnect
a ponzi scheme it was a scam and i went
through all the math on it like there's
no way this is sustainable there's no
way and everyone that was one of my most
disliked videos when i posted this like
three something years ago
and people called me out and they
started making videos about my videos
saying how i didn't know anything
and there were like rebuttals against
what i had to say
and uh i got a lot of hate on that video
what about then but
it didn't yeah but it didn't turn out
for like six months
six months later it turned out to be
this giant scam and you're right then
everyone came back like oh my god
you're right how did you know i'm like
you just it's so simple it's like it's
obviously
it was riding on the wall this is this
is a real question
yeah because i'm i'm personally curious
and i'm sure there's plenty of people
out there thinking exactly how i'm
thinking right now
what do you think of big clout
social media based around cryptocurrency
explain it first yeah so what this is
is that it's the concept of if you want
to invest in a creator right now there's
not a way that you could do that but big
clout
creates a currency that if you want to
invest in me and you think that i'm
going to get more popular over time
you could buy my coin on big cloud and i
would get a
like a finder's fee of anywhere from
like 10 to 50
of what you invest and the hope is that
if i gain more popularity more people
want to buy in
the coin price is going to go up and
you're going to make money yeah um
right now there's no way to get your
money off the platform so you put your
money in oh that's a good one
yeah i didn't know that yeah you put
your money in big cloud
there's your money's there i mean you
can't get that right so let's say
and i know some people by the way i know
some people who have put in like a
hundred grand i kid you not into big
cloud
and now they're worth in big clout money
like five million bucks
i kid you not that's right and they've
made there's no way for them to get that
money out
they didn't know that going into it they
knew it going into it i would never do
that well these are that's the way
that's way too risky these are like
gambling your money what are you doing
here's the thing these are wealthy
people that would have been the
equivalent of me going and being like
all right i'm gonna throw 10 grand in
this and see what happens
what do i think of it i
i don't want to call it i'm i'm highly
suspicious of it and i have to
personally
uh my limit of how much i would put on
and i have no money on there by the way
but i would say
i would make my own personal limit like
a thousand boxes i would be comfortable
throwing a thousand dollars on there
and uh but but that to me is like a
thousand dollars
whatever somebody else a thousand
dollars might be like through life
saving so i wouldn't do that
uh i would i would put in one tenth of
one percent
of your money in big clout and as an
amount that you would be
cons you would lose okay because i don't
want to say that it can't be anything
because i've been so shocked with a lot
of things crypto
like those doge is one of them you know
bitcoin was one of them i actually told
graham
to buy doji really when you bought it
when i bought it less than half a penny
huge regret
what month was that oh i don't know july
i want to say literally a year
oh so you got it off the tick tock wave
yes yeah yeah there was like one tick
tock that i saw
and i had heard of dogecoin before it
was called the dogecoin challenge
yeah was that what it was called i don't
even remember but i watched the video
this was in my last video
so i watched the videos hilarious so
basically the whole premise is that
there are 800 million people on tick
tock
and dogecoin was at zero three cents
they're trying to get to a penny yes so
he uh he did the math
and said we could get this to a dollar
if all 800 million people on tick tock
each invested 25 and then we could turn
our 25
investment into a 10 000 profit
that went viral and the price of
dogecoin went up 43 percent
so on that uh i invested a thousand
dollars
oh yeah i saw the video zero
three something cents today that would
be worth something like
a hundred and fifty thousand dollars
yeah
i sold it right after i ran at the
podcast dude i'm gonna sell it
i sold it uh that's so funny in
hindsight
i should have just left it in just
because like but but then again
i would have sold it 100 when i hit 10
grand there you go if i turned a
thousand into 10 i'd be like
that's good enough yeah yeah so i
there's no way i would have held
throughout all of this okay
my question is how is all of this like
meme investing going to impact real
investing as far as like
money retail money flowing from stocks
into all these kinds of yolo investments
is this
i don't know i wonder how much the stock
market would suffer if people are just
like why would i put money in the stock
market and have to wait eight to ten
years for it to double
if i could just yolo it into a safe moon
coin and then have it 10x in a week
like how is that going to impact the
real form of investment i feel like it's
going to get to a point where
meme economy and meme currency and just
the way
memes are associated with currency in
the future that
it can't be ignored it's going to be a
part of society but you know what i
think
in some ways i also think that's going
to be the catalyst towards regulation
from the government
i think that's what it's going to take i
believe that get taken down someone's
going to get
super badly hurt it could very well be
dogecoin that's the catalyst for the
government to be like
wow look at all these meme investors
they just got hurt yeah let's regulate
the crap out of this
what's going to happen is that the sec
is going to argue that
currencies are actually securities
because right they found a loophole
right now is that like when you buy a
stock
you can't buy something with that stock
you have to sell it so you're buying a
security you're buying investment in the
company
but when you're buying a currency that
you could technically use
for for a purpose of purchasing
something that serves as a token
it's not it's it's it's not a security
so as a currency
there's nothing that says you can't pump
up a currency and sell it and
so you're finding a lot of people right
now legally
promoting these currencies literally as
an open pump and dump
and there's nothing that the sec could
do about it they will find a way and
they did with uh
ripple right with with xrp oh yeah they
treated that
as a security because they i i
don't know exactly how they came to that
conclusion it was something about how it
was structured
but they determined it was the security
and the whole thing didn't they label
some of them as commodities
maybe that was yeah commodities yeah
bitcoin they're like that's a commodity
yeah
so there's something like that so i
think that's the next step because
there's no reason right now that people
should be
we're seeing the whole wave of 2017
again
with like the ice okay so that's another
question i have
i wasn't in the crypto space in 2017
i found out about bitcoin in 2017 when
it was all over the news and i was like
what is this thing going in 17
000 but back to the other point that we
i made earlier about college because i
have money to invest i had zero dollars
so it made okay that's awesome i wish i
could get in on it in some way but i
have no money to do it
so back to my job you know what i mean
like that's what it was like
and obviously there was that crazy crash
right do you think a crash of that
exact same magnitude is going to happen
with
this wave or do you think it's finally
going to
become a part of everyone's life and
implement it in every day 2017
it was really just a case of how high
can this go and 20 000
was what everyone wanted bitcoin to to
go to
everyone thought we're gonna wait till
it hits 20k we're gonna wait
and it hit like 19 970 dollars got a big
dip
and then it like barely hit 20k and that
was like this big celebration of
everyone's like oh we hit 20k
and i i forget oh it was bitconnect went
down
and uh that really set the catalyst
for a lot of cryptocurrencies it was a
bit connect as well as tether
yeah people started to realize what
tether was all about and they're like oh
wow it's these people that are pumping
up the price of bitcoin with their fake
fugazi money
and uh to answer your question i do
think we're going to have that crash
again but people have been
saying the world is ready for crypto
that's what i sensed 2000
probably earlier than 2017. but given
what we know now
dude well the same magnitude as 27
because the thing is this i feel like
more and more people that
never knew anything about crypto has
have started entering the space this
year more so than ever before
like i said in 2017 if you were into
crypto you probably
knew about it earlier on you're probably
in the crypto like it's almost like a
community
right i feel like now this year is
probably the first year
that i'm seeing people say what is
dogecoin what is
like like people that have never bought
a single
cryptocurrency starting today you have
to understand that most people that are
buying these cryptos that have heard
about it for the first time this year
are not buying it because they
understand the underlying technology
they're buying it because they want to
turn their hundred dollars into ten
thousand dollars and so
when it crashes those people are just as
likely to exit as they were in 2017
regardless of how many people are in the
market right
you know what i'll tell you i have i
have two lessons that have really helped
me with this uh
two thousand i've said the story so many
times 2017 i bought into
back at the time it was called ry blocks
what the heck like i've heard of that
yeah right box i i bought in i started
buying it like a dollar fifty
and uh then i started buying it like two
dollars yeah oh yeah exactly
exactly um but that was big back then
ryblocks was supposed to like change the
game it was like
instantaneous transactions it was one of
like the fastest cryptos out there
with the team that like really seemed to
understand what it was all about
yeah and uh it that my investment went
from like
you know i think my average buying was
like two dollars and something went to
like
38 dollars ooh i was sitting on like a
decent amount of profit
and my thinking was i'm gonna sell it at
forty four dollars
because i think it was binance it was
like the coin of the week or something
yeah
and every coin of the week it's like uh
it gets listed on some exchange i think
it was binance
and so it was like 38 and i could
sell instantly and just like lock in the
profit i think
how much was that like 60 grand so it's
50 60 70 grand
and this was like three something years
ago too and
uh it's like you know what i'm gonna
sell when it when i you know when it
hits 44 and they'll be up like a hundred
thousand dollars
yeah it's gonna get listed every coin
that gets listed that's gonna close up
yeah
guess what it comes crashing down
went crashing 43 went down yeah yeah
it crashed to eighty dollars no i'm
kidding and i cashed out i need a whole
bunch like
no no in all seriousness um crypto
started going down
sold off i held on to it thinking that
you know it's gonna get listed yeah
never got listed
had an issue the whole crypto market
crashed that went down to
i think at its lowest point was like a
dollar twenty and you bought in
at two dollars and something so i wrote
it from let's say two dollars
to almost 40 back down to a dollar
what did i write i didn't sell uh nine
dollars right now
i'm still holding i saw i still have my
investment in there believe it or not
because at that point it was like i was
so defeated that i was like
it was more work for me to figure out
how to sell that thing at a dollar so i
just kept it and at this point it
doesn't make a difference another thing
too about 2017 so
yeah uh what was bitcoin right before
the sh the surge like was it about uh
two thousand a thousand two thousand
three thousand dollars yeah it was it
was about two and a half thousand okay
yeah
after the crash happened how low did it
get
how low did it get 30 30 300 so it never
went back that was a 2 000.
no so if you essentially bought in at 2
000 but you were still up you can't
make the equivalence from bitcoin and
apply that to dogecoin like that's not
necessarily how it works okay you can't
be like see that
that happened with bitcoin that must
also happen with dogecoin
because for for every coin that you know
like bitcoin
other crypto alts were you know they
went lower than their lows
but never to zero though right yeah but
they'll never go to zero
any of them like they don't go to zero
because as long as there's one person
holding
it has some form of value okay it's not
gonna go to zero
i think we've done enough convincing him
to sell out i think we should move past
this all right
i think you should try to convince us
why we should invest in dogecoin oh
that's a good one so so kevin he's going
to try to convince you why you need to
invest in doge
and you should try to convince him why
he should sell because he's up two and a
half
million dollars right now let's hear it
so so so kevin
you need to diamond hand this thing okay
all the way to the moon because
at the end of the day this is the way so
when i look at it i see doge as the
future of currency there we go
okay wall street bets at the end of the
day i feel like
doges is the currency of the future i
feel like eventually
we're gonna have memes the same way we
share memes to with each other for free
we're going to end up having memes and
matched up with currency and then i'll
be able to pay you
with a meme and then we're going to buy
and sell memes
is this so like nf team nft memes
basically is that what you're thinking
and then like
doge is the underline somehow some yeah
in some way i feel like that's what's
gonna end up happening
and i feel like the fact that it's a
hundred times better than
fiat currency and the dollar bill and
all that stuff
um i really do believe that one day i'll
be able to go get a haircut
and pay my barber with a dogecoin now
i gotta ask you why why would that
barber take take the volatility risk why
why wouldn't they take bitcoin which
moves
you know not as rapidly up or down or
why wouldn't they just
all right thanks for your doge and
instantly turn it into usd and go buy
some bread
he could do that but if he's a smart guy
he'll hold on to it and then that same
amount of doge will be worth more in the
future
what do you got what's what's doge got
over ethereum or or like cardano
branding branding the fact that it's
the most inviting coin the friendliest
coin the the ease
of use of getting into it like i think
it's the bridge
i think it's the bridge between the real
world and the currency cryptocurrency
world
if somebody wants to get involved in
cryptocurrency the first stop is doge so
everyone's going to have some doge
so maybe bitcoin is too intimidating but
just that friendly
door open come on in and it makes
profits
yeah and it's cheap too so somebody
could get a hundred those coins for a
very little bit of money as opposed to a
percentage of 0.0008 a bitcoin
so it feels maybe more tangible because
you know what's 0.0007 of
the bitcoin no no i got 10 dogs exactly
it's a psychological thing for sure yeah
okay okay that's also
so what's stopping you from taking like
look 300k buying yourself a house right
now in vegas and just having that thing
paid off just just having a little bit
okay we could still run to 10 mil
you know up your projection by by 20
cents or whatever but you'd have a house
paid for it
i could and that's part of the
conversation we're having here you know
i'm open to suggestions
open to different options and taking out
a little bit of money you know a little
percentage here and there
i could totally do and lock in a little
bit of profit
yeah see i already knew that because i
have microphones where they are but hey
that's the side
oh they're there so uh what uh what what
suggestions have you heard how much are
you thinking about taking out are you
gonna go 50
out you're gonna take out your original
graham says a hundred percent
sell just go just let it go now is
do you believe that if you do end up
selling it's going to hurt
the impression of diamond hands i don't
know and that's something we were
talking about like it's
it almost seems like in a weird way i'm
kind of what everyone looks to when
they're buying those because i'm that
success
story and who they look to so it's
almost like i'm this
person who's holding you know what i
mean like diamond hands to the dollar
and and if i can do it they can do it
kind of thing you know what i mean
you're the
roaring kitty of dope roaring yeah yeah
roaring doge
of reddit i mean that's there okay okay
so so
why i mean are you posting updates on on
this amount i mean does anybody need to
know if you
you bought a house you know you sold out
700 and bought a house
real quick does anybody know i might i
might feel like a little fake though
i might feel like a little fraudulent
well
i i maybe maybe but in some sense
uh i think everybody's scratching their
heads a little bit wondering man
well let me let me ask you this okay so
hopefully we can be transparent about
this
what what was your income before this
this doge your your annual like ballpark
six hundred thousand dollars a year oh
sixty thousand sixty k twenty six
hundred three
no no no i make 60k a year okay okay
okay
and what do you do uh i do everything i
do video editing i do narrations i
oversee
you freelancers yeah okay how many hours
a week do you work
at least 40. okay all right so
so right now you're working uh
you know what 40 hours times 46 weeks
you got some time up
you're working around 2 000 hours a year
to make
60 000 after taxes you know maybe you
pay
25 on average in taxes or whatever after
everything
so you got about 45k left over what's
stopping you from taking 45
or 450 000 after taxes out a doge and
going bro
i just make a video about this i just
game the system and in two months
i just got 10 years of my day job of 2
000 hours a year for free you have the
power to do that right now
that is true that is true and that's
part of the success story that i feel
like people can look at and say you know
what he deserves it you know you can
take out a little do that
you do that you still got i don't know
over 1.2 1.3
left in doge fine up your price
you know goal 2 to 3.25 or 5 whatever
it's got to be to get to your 10 mil
but at least before saturday
dude you got in my opinion you got
literally 48 hours to
press a button do i want to guarantee i
don't have to do sh
for the next uh 10 years okay so you're
saying you're saying
you're saying take out 600k i'm saying
take out whatever you need to take out
to have
450 left to where you could say i got
net yeah i guess i mean it'll be the tax
will be a little higher so maybe 650 700
right because your rate will be a little
higher
take that out and then you make us you
do a video about how you just doge just
paid
for 10 years it just paid for 20
000 hours of you doing nothing
if you want for the next 10 freaking
years you have that opportunity you want
to become an
astronaut in those 10 years you can
freaking do it because of doge
whatever you want to be in the next 10
years is financed
by you pushing that button and just part
of it not all out but you locking in
those next 10 years
right now facts and and essentially doge
gave me financial freedom in a way dude
it's the way you branded man
look it's the way you brand it and i
don't think there is a soul on this
planet that is going to go on
in the paper the only people who would
do that
are people who don't have any doge who
don't understand who cares even when
people say you lock in 10 years man
come on man we don't know what this
world is going to be like in 10 years
but i'll tell you you're going to enjoy
the next 10 years as long as you don't
blow it all okay you're going to have to
listen to graham and audrey
so the last thing i want to see you do
is go out and buy well
[ __ ] i'll buy a tesla model s plaid and
now you will go blow a fourth of it on a
stupid piece of you know junk
no don't do that i like tesla
he was talking about wanting it he was
talking about wanting it to go up an
extra like 40 grand so he could buy a
tesla
no no no no no no this is you're going
down a rabbit hole already you're
this is very dangerous you came upon
this money quickly you got to look at
that money
as if it's literally 20 000 hours of
work
and you lock that in don't let it be
play money
let the first 20 look at it in terms of
hours let the first 20 000
hours of work seriously man the first 20
000 hours of work you just saved
let that be guaranteed and then look
after that you hit 10 mil
bro buy your mama bentley and buy
yourself three man i don't give a crap
what you do dude
you can do whatever the hell you want
with the rest man but come on man
max no you're absolutely right you're
absolutely right man i love it thank you
so much
did that convince you or did that change
your mind in any way i like i like
i like the way kevin put it i don't know
isn't it so funny how like we're saying
the same thing we're just trying to say
it in different ways
yeah is she like maybe it's the way he
broke it down and like
out like hours of work and like you
don't have to work these hours anymore
just lock in at least a full two like 10
years or whatever
the way he was saying it we calculated
that you could lock in 31 years
yeah 60 000 hours of your life
or literally a lifetime if you wanted to
yes facts
no that's absolutely true kevin like man
kevin's cool
i like him yeah yeah kevin's cooler than
all of us you guys are close
jack's cool too you're real cool but
kevin is
really cool that guy could run for
governor something he's got a great
smile
is that just so genuine every time i
feel like he really
like he's a great guy he is he's a great
guy for sure
he's cool what's your what's your plan
right now i'm gonna have to like
after this podcast i'm gonna have to
like go to the side and like huddle in
with like
andre and put together a little game
plan but i'm definitely
thinking about doing a move by friday
let's check your portfolio you were out
there
do you remember the exact number at the
beginning of the podcast 2.13 we no 2.2
2.27 right yeah right now it's 2.289 oh
there we go 19 000. yeah
yeah 20 grand roughly
2.325 wow what
two point three two five all right two
point three two four
two point three two four but will you
take a screenshot on that yeah when we
started it was at two
so you just made like 50 grand or
something yeah in like a second
in a second well there's your tesla man
how about you look look at 50 grand
there's
within the past hour i made 50 000 tesla
bro
take out 50 grand right now i'll take
off 50 grand right now
that's just your last hours of profit he
just turned off the phone like a boss
yeah he doesn't
care he's all in wow okay
well pro thank you so much for coming on
this episode of the iced coffee hour it
was great meeting you
i'm in the presence of greatness your
god amongst men thanks graeme thank you
thanks andre thanks andre for coming
back on introducing you guys
really excited to see what happens uh
because by the time this post on
saturday
yeah a lot will have changed and by
sunday i have a feeling this is we're
gonna
we're gonna have some sort of resolution
but something's gonna happen
something is gonna happen it's sunday
we'll put something in the description
if any events happen look for it in the
description we'll update the addition
and we'll have an update you gotta keep
us posting what happens
just go in the description and you'll
see the latest update let's go
what happened down to the hour something
if you if you sell or something you just
shoot us a textbook i got a description
almost instantly let's do it let's do it
oh and also
this episode is sponsored by the clips
channel so
subscribe to the clip's channel it'll be
down in the description thank you all so
much
so with that said you guys thank you so
much for watching i really appreciate it
as always make sure to subscribe
because you haven't done that yet make
sure to subscribe hit the like button
hit the notification bell we'll put all
of our information down below in the
description
get your free stock and with that said
until next time
it's coffee hour yeah my name is pro and
so far i've made whatever
and you can do all that 2.3 million